so today we're going to be learning
about natural line
generation and this is probably going to
be a little difference in my previous
lectures because this is going to be
much more of a kind of survey of lots of
cutting-edge research topics that are
happening in an algae right now so
before we get to that we've got a few
announcements so I guess the main
announcement is just thank you all so
much for your hard work I know the last
week or two have been pretty tough
assignment five was really quite
difficult I think and it was a challenge
to turn eight days so we just really
appreciate all the hard work you put in
we also in sand the project proposal was
sometimes a bit difficult to understand
the expectations for some people so yeah
these are both new components of the
class this year that were not present
last year so you know we have to go
through some learning curves as well as
the teaching staff so just we really
want to say thank you so much for
putting everything into this class and
please do continue to give us your
feedback both right now and in the end
of quarter feedback survey okay so
here's the overview of what we're going
to be doing today so today we're going
to learn about what's happening in the
world of neural approaches for natural
language generation that is a super
super broad title natural language
generation analogy encompasses a huge
variety of research areas and pretty
much each of those could have had their
own lectures and we could have taught us
a whole a whole quart of quarters worth
of classes on energy but we're going to
try to cover a selection of things today
and it's mostly going to be guided by
the things which I've seen that I think
are cool or interesting or exciting so
it's by no means going to be
comprehensive but I hope you're going to
enjoy some of the stuff we're gonna
learn about okay so in particular we're
going to start off by having a recap of
what we already know about natural
language generation to make sure we're
on the same page and we're also going to
learn a little bit extra about decoding
algorithms so we learnt a bit before
about greedy decoding and Bheem said
shoot decoding but today we're going to
learn some extra information about that
and some other types of decoding
algorithms after that we're going to go
through a pretty quick tour of lots of
different energy tasks and a selection
of neural approaches to them and then
after that we're going to talk
about probably the biggest problem in
energy research which is energy
evaluation and why it is such a tricky
situation and then lastly we're going to
have some concluding thoughts on energy
research what are the current trends and
where are we going in the future ok so
section 1 let's do a recap ok
so natural next generation to define it
just refers to any setting in which we
are generating some kind of text so for
example energy is an important sub
component of lots of different tasks
such as machine translation we've
already met abstracted summarization
we'll learn a bit more about that later
dialogue both chitchat and task base
also creative writing tasks such as
writing stories and writing poems even
energy is also sub component of freeform
question answering so I know a lot of
you are doing the squad project right
now that is not an algae task because
you're just extracting the answer from
the the source document but there are
other question answering tasks that do
you have a natural language generation
component image captioning is another
example of a task that has an energy sub
component so energy is a pretty cool
component of a lot of different and RP
tasks all right let's go into our recap
so the first thing I want to recap is
what is language modeling I've noticed
that some people are a little bit
confused about this I think it might be
because the name language modeling
sounds like it might mean just simply
encoding language like representing
language using embeddings or something
so as a reminder language modeling has a
more precise meaning language modeling
is the task of predicting the next words
given the words so far so any system
which produces this conditional
probability distribution that does this
task is called
a language model and if that language
model system is an RNN then we often
abbreviate it as our NN - language model
okay so I hope you remember that the
next thing you know recap is do you
remember what a conditional language
model is the task of conditional
language modeling is when you're
predicting what words going to come next
but you're also conditioning on some
other input X as well as all of your
words so far so to recap some examples
of conditional language of our delaying
include machine translation where you're
conditioning on the source sentence X
summarization you're conditioning on
your input text that you're trying to
summarize dialog you're conditioning on
your dialogue history and so on ok next
we're going to quickly recap how do you
train an RNN language model I guess it
could also be a transformer based
language model or CNN based language
model now that you know about those and
it could be conditional or it could be
not so the main thing I want to remind
you about is that when you are training
this system then you feed in the target
sequence that you're trying to generate
so where it says target sentence from
corpus that's saying that you have some
sequence that you're trying to generate
and you feed that into the decoder the
RNN language model and then it predicts
what words are going to come next so the
super important thing is that during
training we're feeding the gold that is
the reference target sentence into the
decoder regardless of what the decoder
is predicting so even if let's say this
is a very bad decoder that isn't
predicting the correct words it's not
you know critical I'm high at all that
doesn't matter we still just input the
targets with the gold target sequence
into the decoder and I'm slicing this
because it's going to come up later this
training method is called teacher
forcing which might be a phrase that
you've come across elsewhere so yeah he
refers to the fact that the teacher that
is kind of like the gold input is is
forcing the language model to use that
in every step instead of using its own
predictions on each step so that's how
you train a or in a language model which
might be conditional okay so now recap
on decoding algorithms so you've got
your trained language model which might
be conditional the question is how do
you use it to generate text so the
answer is you need a decoding algorithm
a decoding algorithm is an algorithm you
use to generate the text from your
trained language model so in the nmt
lecture a few weeks ago we learned about
two different decoding algorithms we
learnt about greedy decoding and beam
search so let's quickly recap those
greedy decoding is a priest
algorithm on each step you just take
what's the most probable words according
to the language model you could say it's
the odd max and then you use that as an
expert you feed it in as the input on
the next step and you just keep going
until you produce some kind of n token
or maybe when you reach some maximum
length no think you're all quite
familiar with this because you did it in
assignment 5 so yes this diagram shows
how greedy decoding would work to
generate the sentence so as we learned
before
do to work a kind of lack of
backtracking and inability to go back if
you made a wrong choice the output from
greedy decoding is generally pretty poor
like it can be ungrammatical it can be
unnatural kind of nonsensical okay let's
recap beam search decoding so beam
search is a search algorithm which aims
to find a high probability sequence so
if we're doing translation that sequence
is the sequence of translation words by
tracking multiple possible sequences at
once so the core idea is that on each
step of the decoder you're going to be
keeping track of the K most probable
partial sequences which we call
hypotheses and here K is some hyper
hyper parameter called the beam size the
idea is by considering lots of different
hypotheses we're going to try to search
effectively for a high probability
sequence but there is no guarantee that
this is going to be like the optimal
most high probability sequence so at the
end of beam search you reach some kind
of stopping criterion which we talked
about before but I won't cover in detail
again and once you reach your stopping
criterion you choose the sequence with
the highest probability factoring in
some adjustments for length and then
that's our output so just to view this
one more time here's the diagram that we
saw in the nmt lecture of beam search
decoding once it's completed and in this
scenario we have a beam size of two so
this is what it looks like after we've
done this exploration problem this shows
the full tree that we explored and then
we've come some kind of stopping
criterion and we identified the top
hypothesis and that's highlighted in
green so on the subject of beam search
decoding I was watching TV the other day
and I noticed something in West Worlds I
think the hosts the AI hosts in West
world
may be used in search which is something
I wasn't expecting to see on TV so
there's this scene West world is bio a
sci-fi series that has these very
convincing humanoid AI systems and
there's a scene where one of the AI
systems is confronted with the reality
of the fact that she I suppose is not
human because she sees the generation
system of words as she says them and I
was looking at TV and I thought is that
beam search because that diagram looks a
lot like this diagram here but maybe was
a big theme sighs so I thought that was
pretty cool because you know AI has hit
the mainstream when you see beam search
on TV and then if you zoom in really
hard you can see some other exciting
words in this screenshot like knowledge
base forward chaining and backward
chainer identifies the same thing as
forward prop and back with prop and also
fuzzy logic algorithms and neural net so
yeah beam search I think is hit the
mainstream now so it's good enough for
Westworld maybe it's good enough for us
so with beam search right we've talked
about how you have this hyper parameter
K or the beam size and one thing we
didn't talk about in the last lecture so
now we're leaving the recap portion is
what's the effect of changing that beam
size K so if you have a really small K
then you're gonna have similar problems
to greedy
decoding and in fact if K equals 1 then
you are actually just doing 3d decoding
so those same problems are you know
ungrammatical may be unnatural
nonsensical just kind of plain incorrect
output so what happens if you get larger
K if you have a larger beam size then
you're doing your search algorithm but
considering more hypotheses right you're
you are having a larger search space and
you're considering more different
possibilities so if you do that then we
often find that this reduces some of the
problems above so you're much less
likely to have this ungrammatical you
know disjointed output but there are
some downsides to raising K so of course
larger K is more computationally
expensive and I can get pretty bad if
you're trying to for example generate
your outputs for a large you know test
set of n MT examples but more seriously
than
increasing K can introduce some other
problems so for example it's been shown
that in NM t increasing the beam size
too much actually decreases the blue
score and this is kind of
counterintuitive right because we were
thinking of beam search as this
algorithm that tries to find the optimal
solution so surely if you increase K
then you're only going to find a better
solution right so I think maybe the key
here is the difference between
optimality in terms of the search
problem that is finding a high
probability sequence and blue school
which are two separate things and
there's no guarantee that they actually
correspond right and I mean there's a
difference again between blue score and
actual translation quality as we know so
if you look at the T papers which I've
linked to here which are the ones that
show that increasing BM sighs too much
decreases the peace core they explained
it by saying that the main reason why
this happens is because when you
increase the beam size too much then you
end up producing translations that are
too short so I mean that kind of
explains it to a degree the translations
are too short therefore they have low
blue because they're probably missing
words so they should contain but the
question is why does large beam size
give you short translations
I think that's harder to answer when I
read these two papers I didn't see an
explicit explanation of why I think it's
part of a larger kind of pattern we see
sometimes of beam search which is when
you really increase your search space
and make the search much more powerful
so that it can consider lots of
different alternatives it can end up
finding these high probability sequences
which aren't actually the thing that you
want sure they're high probability
probability but they're not actually the
thing that you wanted so another example
of that is that in open-ended tasks like
for example chitchat dialogue where
you're trying to just say something
interesting back to your conversational
partner if we use beam search with a
large beam size we find that that can
give you some output that is really
generic and I'll give you an example
here to show you what I mean so these
are examples from a chitchat dialog
project that I was doing so here you've
got your human hit chitchat partner said
something like I mostly eat fresh and
raw diets so I save on groceries and
then here's why
the chat bot said back depending on the
beam size they read
so I would say that this is fairly
characteristic of what you see happening
when you raise and lower the beam size
when you have a low beam size it might
be more kind of on topic like here we
can see that eat healthy eat healthy I'm
a nurse so I'd you know you raw food and
so on that kind of relates to what the
user said but it's kind of bad English
right now some repetition and it doesn't
always make that much sense right but
then when you raise the beam size then
it kind of converges to a safe so-called
correct response but it's kind of
generic and less relevant right it's
kind of applicable in all scenarios what
do you do for anything so the the the
particular dates that I was using here
is one called persona chat that I'll
tell you more about later but it's a
chit chat dialogue dataset where each
conversational partner has persona which
is a set of traits so the reason it
keeps talking about being a nurse I
think is because it was in the persona
but the main point here is that we kind
of have an unfortunate trade-off with no
with no Goldilocks zone that's very
obvious I mean there's there's a yeah
kind of an unfortunate trade-off between
having kind of bad bad output bad
English and just having something very
boring so this is one of the problems
that we get with beem beem such okay so
we've talked about a greedy decoding and
beam search yes question is can we have
an adaptive beam size dependent on the
position that you're in you mean like in
the sequence yeah yeah yeah I mean I
think I might have heard of a research
paper that does that that adaptively
like raises the capacity of the
hypothesis space it sounds awkward to
implement because you know things
fitting into a fixed space in your GPU
but I think I might be possible I
suppose you'd have to learn the
criterion on which you increase beam
size yeah it seems possible okay so
we've talked about beam search and
greedy decoding so here's a new family
of decoding our
which are pretty simple sampling based
decoding so something which I'm calling
pure sampling because I didn't know what
else to call it this is just the the
simple sampling method that says that on
each time step of your decoder T you
just want to randomly sample from the
probability distribution to obtain your
next word so this is very simple it's
just like greedy decoding but instead of
taking the top words instead just sample
from that distribution so the reason I
call this pure sampling was to
differentiate it from top and sampling
and again this is actually usually
called top K sampling but I already
called K the beam size and I didn't want
to be confusing so I'm going to call it
top and some things now so the idea here
is also pretty simple on each step T you
want to randomly sample from your
probability distribution but you're
going to restrict to just the top and
most probable words so this is saying
that it's like the simple you know pure
sampling method but you want to truncate
your probability distribution just to be
you know the top most probable words so
the idea here kind of like how beam
search gave you a hyper parameter it's
kind of go between greedy decoding and
you know very exhaustive search in the
same way here you've got a hyper
parameter n which can take you between
greedy search and pure sampling if you
think about this for a moment if n is 1
then you truncate at the top one so
you're just taking our max which is
greedy and if n is the vocab size then
you don't truncate it at all
you're something from everything that's
just the pure sampling method so here it
should be clear I hope if you think of
it that if you increase n then you're
going to get more diverse and risky
output right because you're giving it
more more to choose from and you're
going lower into the probability
distribution going lower into less
likely things and then if you decrease n
then you're going to get more kind of
generic safe output because you're
restricting more to the most high
probability options so both of these are
more efficient and beam search which I
think is something important to note
because there are no multiple hypotheses
to track right because in beam search on
every step T of the decoder you've got K
different you know beam size many
hypotheses to track whereas here
if you're only generating one sample
there's only one thing to track so it's
very simple algorithm so that is one
advantage of these sampling based
algorithms over beam search okay so the
last thing I want to tell you that's
kind of related to decoding is softmax
temperature so if you're a cool on time
step T of your decoder your language
model computes some kind of probability
distribution PT by applying the softmax
function to a vector of scores that you
got from somewhere like from your
transformer or familiy or RNA or
something so there's the softmax
function again it's saying that the
probability of a where W is this softmax
function given given the scores so the
idea here over temperature on the
softmax is that you have some kind of
temperature I parameter tau and you're
going to apply that to this softmax so
all that we're doing is with and
dividing all of the schools or logits
you might call them by the temperature
hyper parameter so again if you just
think about this a little bit you'll see
that raising the temperature that is
increasing the hyper parameter this is
going to make your probability
distribution more uniform and this kind
of comes down to the question about when
you when you multiply all of your scores
by a constant how does that affect the
softmax right so do things get more far
apart or less far apart once you take
the exponential so this is something you
can just work out by yourself on paper
but as a kind of a memory shortcut a
good way to think about it is that if
you raise the temperature then the
distribution kind of melts and goes soft
and mushy and uniform and if you lower
the temperature like make it cold then
the probability distribution becomes
more spiky right so like the things
which are rated as high promise you
become like even more disproportionately
high proverty compared to the other
things I think that's easier way to
remember it today I had to work it out
on paper and then I realized it just
that the temperature visualization thing
usually gives me that cracker so one
thing I want to note is that softmax
temperature is not a decoding algorithm
I know that I put it in the decoding
algorithm section that was just because
it's kind of
thing a simple thing that you can do at
test time to change how decoding happens
right you don't need to train with the
softmax temperature so it's not a
decoding algorithm itself it's a
technique that you can apply test time
in conjunction with a decoding algorithm
so for example if you're doing beam
search or you're doing some kind of
sampling then you can also apply a soft
max temperature to change you know
there's kind of risky versus safe
trade-off any questions on this okay so
here's a summary of what we just learnt
about decoding algorithms greedy
decoding is a simple method it gives
kind of low quality output in comparison
to the others at least beam search beam
search especially when you've got a high
beam size it searches through lots of
different hypotheses for a high
probability outputs and this generally
is going to deliver better quality than
greedy search but if the beam size is
too high then you can have these kind of
counterintuitive problems we talked
about before where you've retrieved some
kind of high probability but unsuitable
output so something that's too generic
or something that's too short and we're
going to talk about that more later
something methods are a way to get more
diversity via via randomness well
getting randoms might be your goal in
itself so this is good if you want to
have some kind of for example open-ended
or creative generation setting like a
generating poetry your stories then
sampling is probably a better idea than
beam search because you want to have a
kind of source of randomness to write
different things creatively and top-end
sampling allows you to control the
diversity by changing m and then lastly
softmax temperature is another way to
control the velocities there's quite a
few different knobs you can turn here
and it's not a decoding algorithm it's
just a technique that you can apply
alongside any decoding algorithm
although it wouldn't make sense to apply
it with greedy decoding because even if
you make it more spiky or more flat the
automatics are still the are cracks so
it doesn't make sense ok cool well I'm
going to be more intersection to you so
section 2 is
tasks and neural approaches to them as
mentioned before this is not going to be
an overview of all of energy that would
be quite impossible this is going to be
some selected highlights so in
particular I'm going to start off with a
fairly deep dive into a particular
energy task and I'm a bit more familiar
with and that is summarization so let's
start off with a task definition for
summarization one sensible definition
would be given some kind of input text X
you want to write a summary Y which is
shorter than X and contains the main
information of X so summarization can be
single document or multi documents
single document means that you just have
a summary Y of a single document X in
multi document summarization you're
saying that you want to write a single
summary Y of multiple documents x1 up to
xn and here typically x1 and up to xn
will have some kind of overlapping
content so for example they might all be
different news articles from different
newspapers about the same event right
because it kind of makes sense to write
a single summary that draws from all of
those makes less sense to summarize
things that they're about different
topics there is further subdivision of
task definitions in summarization so I'm
going to describe it via some data sets
here are some different really common
data sets especially in neural
summarization and they kind of
correspond to different like lengths and
different styles of text so a common one
is the gigabyte data sets and the task
here is that you want to map from the
first one or two sentences of a news
article to write the headline and you
could think of this as sentence
compression especially if it's kind of
one sentence to headline because you're
going from a long ish sentence to a
shortish headline style sentence next
one that I wanted to tell you about is
this it's a Chinese summarization data
set but I see people using it a lot and
it's from a microblogging website where
people write summaries of their posts
so the actual summarization task is
you've got some paragraphs of text and
then you want to summarize that into I
think a single sentence summary another
one
two actually are the New York Times and
CNN Daily Mail Dave sets so these ones
are both of the form you've got a whole
news article which is actually pretty
long like hundreds of words and then you
want to summarize that into like maybe a
single sentence or multi sentence
summary the New York Times ones are
written by I think librarians or people
who write summaries for for library
purposes and then one I just spotted
today when I was writing this list is
there's a new fairly new you like last
six months dataset from wikiHow so what
I can tell this seems to be you've got a
full how to article from wiki how and
then you want to boil this down to the
summary sentences which are kind of
cleverly extracted from throughout the
wiki how article they're kind of like
headings so my look at this paper and it
seems that this is kind of interesting
because it's a different type of text as
you might have noticed most of the other
ones are news based and this is not so
that kind of poses different challenges
another kind of division of
summarization is sentence simplification
so this is a related but actually
different tasks in summarization you
want to write something which is shorter
and contains the main information but
this still may be written in just as
complex language whereas in sentence
simplification you want to rewrite the
source text using simpler simple
language right so like simpler word
choices and simpler sentence structure
that might mean it's shorter but not
necessarily say for example simple we
can Wikipedia is a standard data set for
this and the idea is you've got you know
standards Wikipedia and you've got a
simple Wikipedia version and they mostly
align up so you want to map from some
sentence in one to the equivalent
sentence in the other another source of
data for this is newsela which is a
website that rewrites news for children
actually at different learning levels I
think so you have multiple options for
how much it simplifies okay so so that's
the definition or the many definitions
of summarization there's different tasks
so now I'm going to give an overview of
like what are the main techniques for
doing summarization
so there's two main strategies for
summarization you can call them extract
- summarization and abstract or
summarization and the main idea is I
hinted earlier is that in extract -
summarization you're just selecting
parts of the original text to form a
summary and often this will be whole
sentences but maybe you'll be more
granular than that maybe phrases or
words whereas abstract or summarization
you're going to be generating some new
text using energy techniques so the idea
is that it's you know generation from
scratch and my visual metaphor for this
is this kind of like the difference
between highlighting the parts with a
highlighter or writing the summary
yourself or the pen I think the high
level things to know about these two
techniques are the extractor
summarization is basically easier at
least to make a decent system to start
because selecting things is probably
easier than writing text from scratch
but extract a summarization is pretty
restrictive right because you can't
really paraphrase anything you can't
really do any powerful sentence
compression if you can only just select
sentences and of course abstract of
summarization as a paradigm is more
flexible and it's more how humans might
summarize but as noted it's pretty
difficult so I'm going to give you a
very quick view of what pre neural
summarization look like and here we've
got this a diagram from the speech and
language processing book so pre neural
summarization systems were mostly
extractive and like pre neural and MT
which we learnt about in the nmt lecture
it typically had a pipeline which is
what this picture is showing so a
typical pipeline might have three parts
first you have content selection which
is essentially choosing some of the
sentences from the source document to
include and then secondly you're going
to do some kind of information ordering
which means choosing what order should I
put these sentences in and this is
particularly a more non-trivial question
if you were doing multiple document
summarization because your sentences
might come from different documents and
then lastly you're going to your
sentence realization that is actually
turning your selected sentences into
your actual summary so although we're
not doing kind of freeform text
generation there might be some kind of
editing for example
simplifying enticing or removing parts
that are redundant or fixing continuity
issues so for example you can't refer to
a person as she if you never introduce
them in the first place they may be you
need to change change that she to the
name of the person so in particular
these pre neural summarization systems
had some pretty sophisticated algorithms
for content selection so for example you
would have some sentence scoring
functions this is a more simple way you
might do it is you might score all of
the sentences individually and you could
score them based on features such as are
there you know topic keywords in a
sentence if so maybe it's an important
sentence that we should include and you
could compute those keywords using
statistics such as you know tf-idf for
example you can also use pretty basic
but powerful features such as where does
this sentence appear in the document if
it's near the top of the document then
it's more likely to be important
there are also some more complex content
selection algorithms such as for example
there these graph based algorithms which
kind of view the document as a set of
sentences and those sentences are the
nodes of the graph and you imagine that
all sentences sentence pairs have an
edge between them and the weight of the
edge is kind of how similar the
sentences are so then if you think about
the graph in that sense then now you can
try to identify which sentences are
important by finding which sentences are
central in the graph so you can apply
some kind of general-purpose clock graph
algorithms to figure out which nodes of
central and this is a way to find
central sentences okay so back to
summarization is a task we've I can't
remember we talked about rouge already
we've certainly talked about blue but I
can tell you about Rouge now which is
the main automatic metric for
summarization so Rouge stands for R
equal oriented understudy for jesting
evaluation I'm not sure if that was the
first thing they came up with or if they
made it like that to match blue and
here's the here's the equation for well
I suppose one of the Rouge metrics I'll
tell you more about what that means
later and you can read more
in the original paper which is linked to
the bottom so the over idea is that
Rouge is actually pretty similar to blue
it's based on Engram overlap so some
main differences of blue are Rouge
doesn't have brevity penalty I'll talk
more about that in a minute the other
big one is that Rouge is based on recall
while blue is based on precision so you
can see it's there in the title so if
you think about this a little bit I
think you can say arguably precision is
more important for machine translation
that is you only want to generate text
that appears in one of your reference
translations and then to avoid taking a
really conservative strategy where you
only generate really safe things in a
really short translation that's why you
add the brevity penalty to make sure
that it tries to write something long
enough and then by contrast recall is
more important for summarization because
you want to include all the information
the important information in your
summary right so the information that's
in the reference summary is assumed to
be the important information so recall
means that you captured all of that and
I suppose if you assume that you have
maximum length constraint for your
summarization system then those to kind
of give a trade-off right where you want
to include all the information but you
can't be too long as a summary so I
think that's the kind of justification
why you have recall and precision for
these two different tasks however
confusingly often an f-1 that is
combination of precision and recall
version of Rouge is reported anyway in
the summarization literature and to be
honest I'm not entirely sure why this is
maybe it's because of the lack of
explicit max length constraint anyway I
tried search that but I couldn't find an
answer so here's some more information
on Rouge if you remember blue is
reported as a single number right blue
is just a single number and it is a
combination of the Precision's for the
different engrams which is usually one
to fall where as rear scores are usually
reported separately for each Engram so
the most commonly reported rear scores
are reach one Rouge two in Rochelle so
reach one not to be confused
with the rogue one a Star Wars story I
feel like since that phone came out I
see so many people miss typing this and
I think it's related so Rouge one is
based on unigram overlap and Rouge 2
based on diagram overlap it's kind of an
analogy to blue really except recall
based not precision based the more
interesting one is Rouge L which is
longest common subsequence overlap so
the idea here is that you're interested
not only in particular engrams matching
up but in you know how many how long a
sequence of words can you find that
appear in both so you can read more
about these metrics in the paper that
was linked on the previous page and
another really important thing to note
is there's now a convenient Python
implementation of Ridge and maybe it is
not apparent why that's exciting but
it's actually pretty exciting because
for a long time there was just this Perl
script that was quite hard to run and
quite hard to set up and to understand
so someone out there has been here and
has a implemented a pure Python version
version check that it really does match
up to the perl script the people we're
using before so if any of you are using
Rouge or doing summarization for your
projects make sure that you go use that
because it will probably save me some
time okay so we're going to return to
read a little bit later I know that is
assignment for you thought about the
shortcomings of blue as a metric and for
sure Rouge has some shortcomings as well
as a metric summarization and we're
going to come back to that later okay so
we're gonna move on to neural approaches
for summarization so going back to 2015
I don't have another dramatic
reenactment I'm afraid Russia style
published the first seek to seek
summarization paper so they were viewing
this as you know nmt has recently been
super successful why do we view abstract
of summarization as a translation task
and therefore apply standard translation
seek methods to it so that's exactly
what they did and they applied a
standard attention model and then they
did a pretty good job at Giga words
summarization that
the one where you're converting from the
first sentence of the news article for
the headline so it's kind of like
sentence compression so crucially this
is kind of the same order of magnitude
of length as nmt right because nmt is
sentenced a sentence and this is kind of
sentence to sentence maybe at most to
sentence to sentence so this works
pretty well and you can get pretty
decent headline generation or sentence
compression using this kind of method
okay so after that since 2015 there have
been lots more developments in neural
abstractor summarization and you can
kind of group together these
developments in a collection of themes
so one theme is make it easier to copy
this seems pretty obvious because in
summarization you know you're gonna want
to copy over quite a few words and even
phrases but don't copy too much that's
the other thing is that if you make it
too easy to copy then you copy too much
so then there's other research showing
how to prevent too much copying the next
thing is some kind of hierarchical or
multi-level attention so as I just
showed the attention has been pretty key
to attractive neural summarization so
far so there's been some work looking at
you know can we kind of make this
attention work and a more kind of
high-level low-level course file version
so that we can kind of maybe do our
selection at a high level and as lower
level another thing which is kind of
related is having some more kind of
global content selection so you remember
when we were talking about the the
pipeline's pre neural summarization they
had these different content selection
algorithms and I think you can say that
kind of naive attention attention seek
to seek is not necessarily the best way
to do content selection for
summarization maybe you want a more kind
of global strategy where you choose
what's important it's not so apparent
here when you're doing this small-scale
summarization but if you imagine that
you're summarizing a whole news article
and you're choosing which information
kind of deciding on each decoder step
what to choose doesn't seem like the
most global strategy what else we got
there's using a reinforcement learning
to directly maximize Rouge or other
discrete goals you might care about such
as maybe the length of the summary and I
say discrete here because Rouge is a non
differentiable function of your
generated outputs there's no easy way to
eventually learned that during training
in the usual way my last point on this
list is the kind of theme of
resurrecting pre neural ideas such as
those graph algorithms that I mentioned
earlier and working them into these new
seek seek attractive neural systems and
I'm sure there's more as well
so I'm gonna show you a few of these
especially because even if you're not
particularly interested in summarization
a lot of the ideas that we're going to
explore here actually kind of applicable
to other areas of energy or just other
areas of NRP tea planning so the first
thing on the list is making it easier to
copy which seems like probably the first
thing you want to fix if you've just got
basic secret attention so a copying
mechanism which can exist outside of
summarization the reason why you run
this is the basics eat seek with
attention they're good at writing fluent
output as we know but they're pretty bad
at copying over details like rare words
correctly so a copy mechanism is just
the kind of sensible idea of saying
let's have an explicit mechanism to just
copy over words so for example you could
use the attention distribution to to
kind of select what you're going to copy
so if you're allowing both copying over
words and generating words in the usual
way with your language model the now
you've got a kind of hybrid extractive
abstractive approach to summarization so
there are several papers which are which
propose some kind of copy mechanism
variants and I think the reason why
there's multiple is because there's kind
of a few different choices you can make
about how to implement this and that
means that there's a few different
versions of how to implement a copy
mechanism so yeah there's several papers
here which you can look at I'm going to
show you a diagram from a paper that I
did a few years ago with Chris so this
is just one example of how you can do a
copying mechanism so the way we did it
is we said that on each decoder step
you're going to calculate this
probability P gen and that's the
probability of generating the next word
rather than copying it and the idea is
that this is computed based on your
current kind of context your current
decoding end State so then once you've
done that then the idea is you've got
your attention distribution as normal
and you've got your kind of output you
know generation distribution as normal
and you're going to use this P gen which
is just a scalar you're going to use
that to kind of combine mix together
these two probability distributions so
what this equation is telling you is
that saying that the final output
distribution for what words going to
come next it's kind of saying is the
probability of generating times your
probability distribution of what you
were generates but then also the
probability of copying and then also
what you're attending to at that time so
the main things are using attention as
you're copying mechanism so attention is
kind of doing double-duty here it's both
being useful for the generator to you
know maybe choose to rephrase things but
it's also being useful as a copying
mechanism and I think that's one of the
several things that these different
papers do differently I think I've seen
a paper that maybe has like two separate
attention distributions one for the
copying and one for the attending are
the choices you can make differently are
for example do you want P gen to be this
kind of soft thing that's between 0 and
1 or do you want it to be a hard thing
that has to be either 0 or 1 you can
also make decisions about like do you
want the PG n to have supervision during
training do you want to kind of annotate
your data set saying these things are
copied things these things are not or do
you want to just like learn it end to
end so there's multiple ways you can do
this and this has now become pretty
pretty standard
okay so conformation ISM seems like
seems like a sensible idea but there's a
big problem with them which is what I
mentioned earlier and that problem is
that they copy too much so when you when
you run these kind of systems on
summarization you find that they end up
copying a lot of long phrases and
sometimes even whole sentences and
unfortunately your dream of having and
abstractive summarization system isn't
going to work out because you're you
know copy augmented seek seek system has
just collapsed into a mostly extractive
system which is unfortunate another
problem with these coping mechanism
models is that they are bad at overall
content selection especially the input
document is long and this is what I was
hinting at earlier
that's supposing you are summarizing
something that's quite long like a news
article that's hundreds of words long
and you want to write a several sentence
it doesn't seem like the kind of
smartest choice to on every step of
writing your several sentence summary be
choosing again what to attend to what to
select what to summarize it seems better
to kind of make a global decision at the
beginning and then summarize so yeah the
problem is there's no overall strategy
for selecting the content so here's the
paper that I've found nope not yet okay
so how might you do better content
selection for Nero summarization so if
you remember in this pre neural
summarization we looked at you had
completely separate stages in the
pipeline right you had a Content
selection stage and you had a surface
realization that is the text generation
stage but in our seat seek attention
systems these two stages are just
completely mixed together right you're
doing your step by step surface
realization that is text generation and
then on each of those who are also doing
content selection so yeah this doesn't
make sense
so I found a paper which is a published
I think last year which gives a quite
nice kind of simple solution to this
problem and it's called bottom-up
summarization so in this paper if you
look at the if you look at the figure
the main idea is pretty simple it says
that first you're gonna have a content
selection stage and this is just thought
of as a neural sequence tagging model
problem right you run through your
source document and you kind of tag
every word as include or don't include
so you're just kind of deciding like
what seems important what seems like it
should make it into the summary and what
doesn't and then the bottom-up attention
stage says that now you'll see seek with
a tension system which is going to
generate the summary you're going to
kind of apply a mask you know apply a
hard constraint that says you can't
attend to words that were tags don't
include so this turns out to be pretty
simple but effective because it's a
better overall content selection
strategy because by doing this first
content selection stage fine secrets
tagging you're kind of just doing the
selection thing without also at the same
time doing the the generation thing
which I think turns out to be a better
way to make better decisions about what
to include and then separately this also
means as a great side effect you have
less copying
long sequences in the generation model
because if you're not allowed to attend
to things which you shouldn't be
including then it's kind of hard to copy
a really long sequence right like if you
want to copy a whole a whole sentence
but the sentence has plenty of don't
include well it's an it then you can't
really copy a long sequence you have to
break it up so what the model ends up
doing is it kind of has to skip skip
around to the parts as meant to include
and then it's forced to be more abstract
'iv to put the parts together yep
masking decisions during training hardly
back in season mask uses yeah I think it
might be trained separately I know she
can go check the paper I've read a lot
of papers and last days I can't remember
I think it might be trained separately
but they might have tried training it
together but it didn't write as well I'm
not sure you can check it out okay so
another paper I want to tell you about
is a paper which used reinforcement
learning to directly maximize Rouge for
neural summarization so this was a paper
from two years ago and the main idea is
they can use RL to directly optimize in
this case Rachelle the metric so by
contrast the standard maximum likelihood
training that is the the training
objective we've been talking about for
the whole class so far the language
models that contact lis optimize usual
because it's a non differentiable
function so they use this RL technique
to compute the Reus scored during
training and then use a reinforcement
learning to back prop to the model so
the interesting finding from this paper
is that if they just use the RL
objective then they do indeed get higher
rear scores so they can successfully
optimize this rachelle metric that they
were aiming to optimize but the problem
is that when you do that you get lower
human judgement scores so on the right
we're seeing that the r ellonija model
has actually pretty pretty bad
readability relevance human judgement
scores it's worse than just the maximum
likelihood
supervised training system so this is a
quote from their blog post they said we
observed in our models with the highest
scores also generated barely
readable summaries so this is this is um
I suppose a problem right if you try to
directly optimize for the metric then
you might start finding that you're kind
of gaming the metric and not optimizing
for the true task right because we know
just as we knew that blue was not a
really a perfect analogy to actual
translation quality so is Rouge not a
perfect analogy to summarization quality
but they did do something cool which is
they found that if you combine the two
objectives so they kind of you know
predict the language model sequence
objective and then they're also like
could use an overall summary that gets a
higher score objective and you combine
them together then you can get a better
human judgment scores which in the end
is the closest thing we have to a
measure of actual summarization quality
okay so I'm gonna move on to dialogue
which is a different energy kind of
family of tasks
so really dialogue encompasses a really
large variety of settings and we're not
going to cover them all but here's a
kind of overview of all the different
kinds of tasks that people might mean
when they say dialogue
so there's task oriented dialogue and
this kind of refers to any setting where
you're trying to kind of get something
done in the conversation so for example
we've got kind of assistive tasks where
it's assumed that you have you know
maybe the dialogue agent is trying to
help a human user do something like
maybe giving customer service or
recommendations answering questions
helping the user you know accomplish a
task like buying or booking something
these are the kinds of tasks which the
virtual assistant or your phone can do
or can kind of do another family of task
oriented dialogue tasks are cooperative
tasks so this is kind of anything where
you've got two agents who are trying to
solve the task together via dialogue and
the opposite of that would be
adversarial so anything we have two
agents who are trying to compete in a
task and that competition is conducted
through dialogue so the opposite to task
oriented dialogue is social dialogue so
that's something where there is no
explicit task other than to I suppose
socialize so chitchat dialogue
is just dialogue where you're just doing
it for social fun or for company I've
also seen some work on kind of like
therapy or mental well-being dialogue
and also this should go in tasks or
social that's kind of a mix but I
suppose these are ones where the goal is
to maybe offer kind of emotional support
to the human user so as a very kind of
brief overview of how the deep learning
Renaissance has kind of changed dialogue
research I think you could say that kind
of pre deep learning the difficulty of
open-ended freeform natural language
generation meant that dialogue systems
were often not doing freeform energy
they might use predefined templates
meaning that you have a template where
you just fill in some slots with the
content or maybe you retrieve an
appropriate response from a corpus of
responses that you have in order to find
you know an appropriate response for the
user and these are by no means simple
systems they had some very complex
things going on like deciding you know
what the dialogue state is and what
template you should use and and so on
and the all the natural language
understanding components of
understanding the context so far but one
effect that deep learning had is that
since again kind of 2015 which is when
nmt became standards there's been just
like summarization lots of papers
applying seek methods to dialogue and
this has kind of led to a renewed
interest in open-ended freeform dialogue
systems so if you want to have a look at
what are those early seek seek dialog
papers look like here's two kind of
early ones like maybe the first ones to
apply seek seek okay so people quickly
applied teach seek nmt methods to
dialogue but it quickly became very
apparent that this kind of naive
application of standard nmt methods has
some serious pervasive deficiencies when
applied to a task like chitchat dialogue
and this is even more true than it was
for summarization so what are some
examples of these serious is a pervasive
deficiencies one would be generic honest
or boring responses and I'll go into
more detail about these in a moment
another one is irrelevant
sponsors so that's when the dialogue
agent kind of says something back that's
just kind of unrelated to what the user
says another one is repetition this is
pretty basic but it happens a lot so
that's also a repetition within the
utterance and maybe repetition across
utterances another difficulty is a kind
of lack of context like not remembering
the conversation history obviously if
you do not condition on the whole
conversation history there's no way your
log aging can use it but it is a
challenge especially if you have a very
long dialogue history to figure out how
to condition on it effectively another
problem is the lack of consistent
persona so if you kind of naively as in
maybe those two papers that I referenced
on the previous slide if you naively
train kind of standard seat stick model
to maybe take the you know the users
last cut rinse and then say something
back or maybe even the whole dialogue
history and say something back often
your dialog agent will have this
completely inconsistent persona like one
moment it will say that it lives in
Europe and then also lives in I don't
know China or something and it just
doesn't make sense so I'm gonna go
through some of these problems and give
you a bit more detail on them so first
this irrelevant response problem so in a
bit more detail your problem is that CDC
is often generated some response that's
kind of unrelated to the users utterance
so it can be unrelated because it's
simply generic which means that this is
kind of like an overlap with a generic
response problem or it can be kind of
unrelated because the models choosing to
kind of change to change the subject to
something unrelated so one solution of
many there there are a lot of different
papers which kind of attack this a
relevant response problem but just one
front one for example is that you should
change the training objective so instead
of trying to optimize mapping from input
s to response T such that you're
maximizing the conditional probability
of T given s instead you should maximize
the maximum mutual information so that's
what this is here so maximum mutual
information you can kind of rewrite the
objective like this and if you want to
see some more detail you can go look at
this paper here but the idea is that
you're trying to find your response T
that kind of maximizes this thing which
is kind of like saying it needs to be
probable given the inputs but kind of
like
a ratio of its probability in itself so
if T is very high likelihood than it
gets penalized and it's kind of like
about the ratio of the probability given
the input and just the standard and
probability so the idea is that this is
meant to discourage just saying generic
things that just have a high PT by
themselves so that's the relevant
response problem and as I just into that
there's definitely a strong link between
the irrelevant response problem and the
kind of generic or boring response
problem so to look at the generic Nisour
boring response problem so I think there
are some pretty easy fixes that you can
make to to a degree ameliorate the
boring response problem whether you're
really getting to the heart of the issue
is a different question but some kind of
easy test time fixes that you can
certainly do are for example you can
just directly up rate up wait rare words
during beam search so you can say all
rare words kind of get a boost to their
log probabilities and then now we're
more likely to produce them during beam
search another thing you can do is you
could use for example a sampling
decoding algorithm rather than beam
search and we talked about that earlier
or you could use oh yeah you could use
soft max temperature as well that's
another thing so there's a kind of test
time fixes and you could regard those as
a kind of late intervention right so an
earlier intervention would be maybe
training your model differently so I'm
calling these kind of conditioning fixes
because these fixes kind of relate to
conditioning your model on something
that's gonna help it be less boring so
one example is maybe you should
condition the decoder on some kind of
additional context so for example
there's some work showing that you know
if you're doing chitchat dialogue then
maybe you should go in sample some
related words that are related to what
the user said and then just kind of
attend to them when you generate and
then you're more likely to say something
that's kind of content full and
interesting compared to the boring
things you were saying before another
opportunity is you could train a
retrieve and refine model rather than a
generate from scratch model so by
retrieving refine I mean you suppose
that you have some kind of
of just general kind of utterances
things you could say and then maybe you
sample one from that test set that the
it was a training set and then you edit
it to fit the current situation so it
turns out that this is a pretty strong
method to produce much more kind of
diverse and human-like and interesting
utterances because you can get all of
that kind of fine-grained detail from
the samples utterance and then you edit
it as necessary to fit your current
situation so I mean there are downsides
of these kinds of methods like maybe it
can be hard to edit it to actually
appropriately fit the situation but it's
certainly a way to effectively get like
some more diversity and interest in that
so on the subject of the repetition
problem that was another kind of a major
problem we notice for applying seat seek
to chit chat again there are kind of
simple solutions and more complex
solutions so a simple solution is you
could just lock repeating engrams during
beam search and this is usually really
quite effective and what I mean by that
is during beam search when you're kind
of considering you know what are my K
hypotheses which is just kind of the top
K in the probability distribution you
say well anything that would constitute
you're repeating Engram just gets thrown
out so when I say constitutes you're
using M Graham I mean if you did take
that word would you now be creating a
repeating let's say to Graham diagram
and if we're deciding that we're banning
all repeating programs or trigrams or
whatever then you essentially just have
to check for every possible word that
you might be looking at in beam search
whether that words create a repeating
Engram so this works pretty well I mean
it's by no means a kind of principled
solution right it feels like we should
kind of have a better way to learn not
repeat but is a kind of effective hack I
think that works that works very well so
some more complex solutions are for
example you can train something called
coverage mechanism so in situ seek and
this is mostly inspired by the machine
translation setting a coverage mechanism
is a kind of objectives that prevents
the attention mechanism from attending
to the same words multiple times or too
many times and the intuition here is
that maybe repetition is caused by
repeated attention so if you attends the
same thing as many time
then maybe you're going to repeat you
know the same output many times so if
you prevent the repeated attention you
prevent the repeated output so this does
work pretty well but it's definitely
more of a complex thing to implement as
less convenience and I don't know in
some settings that does seem like the
simple solution is easier and works just
as well
so other complex solutions might be you
could define a training objective to
discourage repetition this could you've
tries to define something differentiable
but one of the difficulties there is
that because you're training with a
teacher forcing right where you're
always like looking at the the gold
input so far then you never really do
the thing where you generate your own
output and start repeating yourself so
it's kind of hard to define the penalty
in that situation so maybe this needs to
be a kind of non differentiable function
so kind of like how the poreless a tile
paper was optimizing for Rouge maybe we
kind of optimize for non repeating which
is a discrete function of the input I'm
gonna skip ahead to storytelling so in
storytelling there's a lot of
interesting neural storytelling work
going on right now and most of it uses
some kind of prompt to write a story so
for example writing a story given an
image or given a writing prompt or
writing the next sentence of the story
given the story so far so here's an
example of generating a story from an
image and what's interesting here is
that we have this image which is a
picture of what appears to be an
explosion and then here you have a story
about the image but written in the style
of Taylor Swift lyrics so it says you
have to be the only light bulb in the
night sky I thought oh god it's so dark
House of me that I missed you I promise
and what's interesting here is there
wasn't any straightforward supervised
you know image captioning data set you
know explosions and Taylor Swift lyrics
they kind of learned this separately so
how they did this is that they used a
kind of common sentence encoding space
so they use this particular kind of
sentence encoding called skip thought
vectors and then they trained this coco
image captioning
system to go from the image to the
encoding of the sentence and then
separately they also trained a language
model a conditional language model to go
from the sentence and coding to the
Taylor Swift lyrics and then because you
had this shared encoding space you can
now put the two together and then go
from the the picture to the embedding to
the Taylor Swift style output which i
think is pretty pretty amazing well I've
really lost lost track of the time so I
think I have to hurry up quite a lot so
we've got some really impressive story
generation systems recently and this is
an example of a system which provides
new dataset where you write a story
given a prompt and they made this very
impressive very beefed up convolutional
language model seek seek system that
generates the story given the input and
I'm not gonna go through all these
details but I encourage you if you want
to check out what's the state of the art
in story generation you should check us
out there's a lot of different
interesting things going on with very
fancy attention and convolutions and so
on and they managed to generate some
really interesting impressive stories so
here if you look at this example we've
got some really interesting kind of
story generation that's kind of diverse
it's non-generic it's stylistically
dramatic which is good and it's related
to the prompt but I think you can see
here kind of the limits of what this
state of the art story generation system
can do which is that although it's kind
of in style it's mostly kind of
atmospheric and descriptive it's not
really moving the power forward there's
no kind of events here right so the
problem is this gets even worse when you
generate for longer when you generate a
long a long text and it will mostly just
stay on the same idea without moving
forward with new ideas okay so I'm going
to skip forward I have a lot and sorry
not to have planned better there's a lot
of information here which you want to
check out about post generation and
other things I'm gonna skip head because
I want to get to the nlg evaluation
section because that's pretty important
so we've talked about automatic
evaluation metrics for energy and we
know that these words overlap based
metrics such as blue and Rouge and
meteor we know they're not ideal for
machine translation
they're kind of even worse for
summarization mostly because
summarization is even more open-ended
than machine translation and that means
they're having this kind of rigid notion
if you've got to match the engrams is
even less suitable and then for
something even more open-ended like
dialogue then it's just kind of a
disaster it's not even a metric that
gives you a good signal at all and this
also applies for anything else
open-ended like story generation so it's
been shown and you can check out the
paper at the bottom that words overlap
metrics are just not a good fit for
dialogue so the orange box is showing
you some plots of the correlation
between human score on a dialogue cask
and blue to where some variation of blue
and the problem here is you're not
seeing much for correlation at all right
it seems that particularly on this
dialogue setting the correlation between
the blue metric and the human judgement
of whether it's a good dialogue response
is the correlation is I mean it looks
kind of non-existent it's at least very
weak so that's pretty unfortunate and
there's some other papers that show much
the same thing so you might think well
what other automatic metrics can be used
what about the Flex tee so perplexity
certainly captures how powerful your
language model is but it doesn't tell
you anything about generation so for
example if you're decoding algorithm is
bad in some way then perplexity is not
going to tell you anything about that
right because decoding is something you
apply to your trained language model but
XT can tell you've got a strong language
model or not but there's not going to
tell you necessarily how good your
generation is so it's mostly what you
might have about automatic evaluation or
well what about words embedding based
metrics so the main idea with word
embedding based metrics are you want to
compute the similarity of the word
embeddings or maybe if the average of
the word embeddings across the sentence
not just the overlap of the words
themselves so the idea is that rather
than just being very strict and saying
only the exact same word counts you say
well if the words are similar in word
embedding space then they count so this
is certainly more flexible but
unfortunately the same paper I showed
before shows that this doesn't correlate
well either with human judgments of
quality at least further to start the
dialogue tasks they are looking at so
here the middle column is showing the
correlation between human judgments and
some kind of average of word embedding
based metric so yeah that doesn't look
great either not a great correlation so
if we have no automatic metrics to
adequately capture overall quality for
natural language generation what what
can we do instead so I think often the
strategy is you end up defining some
more kind of focused automatic metrics
to capture the particular aspects of the
generated text that you might be
interested in say for example you might
be interested in fluency and you could
compute that by just kind of running a
well trained language model over your
text and generating the probability and
that's kind of a proxy for how well it's
written you know good fluent grass
context if you're particularly
interested in maybe generating text in a
particular style then you could take a
language model that's trained on the
corpus representing that style and now
the probability tells you not only is it
you know good text but is it in the
right style there are some other things
as well they're like you know diversity
and you can count that pretty easily by
just having some statistics about you
know how it's you're using real words
relevance to input you kind of compute a
similarity score with the input and
there are just some simple things like
you know length and repetition that you
surely can count and yes it doesn't tell
you overall the overall quality but
these things are worth measuring so I
think my main point is that yes we have
a really difficult situation with energy
evaluation there's no kind of overall
metric often they captures very virile
quality but if you measure lots of these
things then they certainly can help you
track some important things that you
should know so we've talked about how
automatic evaluation metrics for energy
are really tough so let's talk about
human evaluation
human judgments are regarded as the gold
standard right but we already know that
human evaluation is slow and expensive
but are those the only problems with
human eval let's suppose that you do
have access to let's say the time or
money you need to do human evaluations
does that solve all your problems
suppose you have unlimited human eval
does that actually solve your problems
and my answer is no and this is kind of
from personal experience conducting
human evaluation in itself is very
difficult to get right it's not easy at
all and this is partially because humans
do a lot of where things humans are
unlike a
trick are an automatic metrics they're
inconsistent they could be illogical
sometimes they just get bored of your
task and they don't really pay attention
anymore they can misinterpret the
question you asked and sometimes they do
things they can't really explain why
they did it so as a kind of case study
this I'm going to tell you about a
project I did where I was building some
chat BOTS and it turns out that the
human evaluation was kind of the hardest
part of the project so I was trying to
build these chat box for the persona
chat dataset and in particular
investigating controllability so we're
trying to control aspects of the
generated text such as you know whether
your people solve how generic you are
kind of these same problems that we
noted before so we build these models
that control you know the specificity of
what we're saying and how related what
we're saying is to what the user said so
here you can see that you know our
partner said something like yes I'm
studying law at the moment and we can
kind of control turn the control knob
that makes us say something very generic
like oh and then like twenty dots or
something just completely bonkers it's
just all the rare words you know and
there's like a sweetness sweet spot
between what you say that sounds like a
lot of fun how long have you been
studying and then similarly we have a
knob we can turn to determine how
semantically related what we say is to
what what they said so you know that's
kind of interesting it's a way to
control the outputs of the energy system
but actually I want to tell you about
how the human evaluation was so
difficult so we had these systems that
we wanted to generate using human evil
so the question is how do you ask for
the human quality judgments here you can
ask kind of simple overall quality
questions like you know how well does
this conversation go versus user
engaging or maybe comparison which of
these users gave a better response
questions like this and you know we
tried to loss of them but there were
just major problems with all of them
like these questions are necessarily
very subjective and also the different
respondents have different expectations
and this affects their judgments so for
example if you ask do you think this
user is a human or a bot then well that
depends entirely on this respondents
knowledge of box for opinion of bots and
what they think they can do another
example is you'd have kind of
catastrophic misunderstanding of the
question so for example if we ask was
this user was this chat bot engaging
then someone responded saying yep it was
engaging because it always wrote back
which clearly is what we meant so we men
like are they an engaging conversation
partner but they took a very literal
assumption of what engaging means so the
problem here is that overall quality
depends on many underlying factors and
it's pretty hard to kind of find a
single overall question that captures
just overall quality so what we ended up
doing is we ended up breaking this down
into lots more kind of factors of
quality so the way we saw it is that you
have maybe these kind of overall
measures of quality of the chatbots such
as how engaging was it how enjoyable was
it to talk to you and kind of maybe how
convincing wasn't that it was human and
then below those we kind of broke down
it sees more low level components of
quality such as you know were you
interesting were you showing your
listening were you asking enough
questions and so on and then below that
we had these kind of controllable
attributes which were the knobs that we
were turning and then the goal was to
figure out how these things affected the
output so let's see so we had a bunch of
findings here and I think like maybe the
ones which I will highlights were these
two kind of in the middle
so the overall metric engaging us which
means enjoyment that was really easy to
maximize it turned out our bots managed
to get kind of near human performance in
terms of engaging us
but the overall metric humanists that is
the kind of Turing test metric that was
not at all easy to maximize all of our
BOTS were way way below humans in terms
of humanists right so we were not store
convincing there being human and this is
kind of interesting right like we were
as enjoyable to talk to as humans but we
were clearly not human right so like
humanists is not the same thing as
conversational quality and one of the
interesting things we found in this
study where we not only evaluated our
chat box we also actually got humans to
evaluate each other was that humans are
suboptimal conversation lists they
scored pretty poorly on interestingness
fluency listening they didn't ask each
other enough questions and this is kind
of a reason why we managed to like
approach human performance in kind of
enjoyable nurse to talk to you because
we just for example turned up the
question asking nob ask more questions
and people responded really well to that
because people like talking about
themselves
so yeah I think this is kind of
interesting right because it shows that
there's no obvious just one question two
it's great because if we'd assumed oh
the one question to ask is clearly
engaging us or it's clearly humaneness
then we would have got completely
different reads on how well we were
doing right
whereas asking these multiple questions
kind of gives you more of an overview I
am going to skip this just because
there's not a lot of time okay so here's
the final section and this is my kind of
wrap-up thoughts on energy research the
current trends and where we're going in
the future so here's kind of three
exciting current trends identified in
energy and of course your mileage may
vary you might think that other things
more interesting so the ones which I was
thinking about are firstly incorporating
discrete latent variables into nlg so
you should go check out the slides I
skipped over because there were some
examples of this but the idea is that
with some tasks such as for example
storytelling or task oriented dialogue
where you're trying to actually get
something done you probably want a more
kind of concrete hard notion of the
things you're talking about like you
know entities and people and events and
you know negotiation and so on so
there's there some interesting work kind
of modeling these discrete nation
variables inside these continuous energy
methods the second one is alternative
stripped left to right generation and
I'm really sorry I skipped over so many
things so there's some interesting work
recently in trying to generate text in
ways other than left-to-right so for
example there's some kind of parallel
generation stuff or maybe writing
something in iteratively refining it
there's also the idea of kind of
top-down generation for especially
longer pieces of text like maybe try to
decide the content of each of the
sentences separately before writing the
words and then a third one is like
alternatives to maximum likely a
training with teacher forcing so it's a
reminder maximum likelihood training
with teacher forcing is just the
standard method of training a language
model that we've been telling you about
in the class so far so you know there's
some interesting work on looking at more
kind of holistic sentence level rather
than word level objectives so I'm
fortunate around a time with a slide I
didn't have time to put the references
in but I will put the references in
later and it will be on the course
website so you can go check them out
later okay
so as a kind of overview analogy
research where are we and where are we
going
so my metaphor is I think that about
five years ago NLP and deep learning
research was a kind of a Wild West right
like everything was new and we were
unsure and I'll be researchers weren't
sure kind of what the new research
landscape was because you know neural
methods kind of changed machine
translation a lot and look like they
might change other areas but it was
uncertain how much but these days you
know five years later it's a lot less
wild I'd say you know things are settled
down a lot kind of standard practices
have emerged and sure there's still a
lot of things changing but you know
there's more people in the community
there's more standard practices we have
things like tents flow and pi torch so
you don't have to take our gradients
anymore so I'd say things are a lot less
wild now but I would say energy does
seem to be one of the wildest spots
remaining and part of the reasons for
that is because of the lack of
evaluation metrics that makes are so
difficult to tell what we're doing it's
quite difficult to identify like what
are the main methods that are working
when we don't have any metrics that can
clearly tell us what's going on so
another thing that I'm greedy guard to
see is that the neural energy community
is rapidly expanding so in the early
years people were mostly transferring
successful nmt methods to various energy
tasks but now I'm seeing you know
increasingly more inventive energy
techniques emerging which is specific to
the non nmt generation settings and
again I just go back and look at the
slices I skips so I'm also seeing
there's increasingly more kind of neural
energy workshops and competitions
especially focusing on open-ended energy
like those tasks that we know are not
well suited by the automatic metrics
that work for nmt so there's a neural
generation workshop a storytelling
workshop and various challenges as well
where people enter there for example
conversational dialogue agents to be
evaluated against each other so I think
that these different kind of community
organizing workshops and competitions
are really doing a great job to kind of
organize a community increase
reproducibility and standard evaluate
stands lies about your evaluation so
this is great but I'd say the biggest
robot progress is definitely still
okay so the last thing I want to share
with you is eight things that I've
learned from working in NRG so the first
one is the more open end of the task
that the harder everything becomes
evaluation becomes harder defining what
you're doing becomes harder telling when
you're doing a good chunk becomes harder
so for this reason constraints can
sometimes make things more welcome so if
you decide to constrain your task then
sometimes it's easier to complete it the
next one is aiming for a specific
improvement can often be more manageable
than aiming to improve overall
generation quality so for example if you
decide that you want to well for example
a increased diversity of your model
likes a more interesting things that's
an easier thing to achieve and measure
than just saying we want to do overall
generation quality because of the
evaluation problem the next one is if
you're using a language model to do NRG
then improving the language model that
is getting better with LexA T will give
you probably better generation quality
because you've got a stronger language
model but it's not the only way to
improve generation quality as we talked
about before there's also other
components that can affect generation
apart from just the language model and
that's part of the problem is that
that's not in the training objective my
next tip is that you should look at your
output a lot partially because you don't
have any single metric that can tell you
what's going on it's pretty important to
look at your output a lot to form your
own opinions it can be timings consuming
but it's probably worth doing I ended up
talking to these chat BOTS a huge amount
during the time that I was working on
the project
okay almost done so fight you need an
automatic metric even if it's perfect so
I know they already know this because
we've wrote it all all over the project
instructions but I probably meant that
too like maybe you need several
automatic metrics I talked earlier about
how you might track multiple things to
get an overall picture of what's going
on
I'd say the more open-ended your energy
task is the more likely you need
probably several metrics if you do human
eval you want to make the questions as
focused as possible so as I found out
the hard way if you define the question
is a very kind of overall vague thing
then you're just opening yourself up to
the respondents kind of misunderstanding
you and if they're doing that then it's
actually not their fault it's your fault
and you need to change your questions
and that's what I learned the next thing
is reproducibility is a huge problem in
today's NLP nt planning in
and the problem is only bigger in energy
I guess it's another way that it's still
a Wild West
so I'd say that it'll be really great if
everybody could publicly release all of
their generated output when they write
energy papers I think this is a great
practice because if you release your
generated outputs then if someone later
let's say comes up with a great
automatic metric then they can just grab
your generated output and then compute
the metric on that whereas if you never
released your output or your released
with some kind of imperfect metric
number then future researchers have
nothing to compare against so lastly my
last thoughts about working in energy is
that it can be very frustrating
sometimes because things can be
difficult and it's hard to know when
you're making progress
but the upside is they can also be very
funny so this is my last slide here are
some bizarre conversations that I've had
with my chat bot
all right thanks